so
we talked about the anatomy of poise
circles of spinning circles
basically when you're spinning something
it's rotational energy wants to
normalize into a plane
which is why we end up talking about
playing so much with koi
when you're spinning in a particular
plane making the circle
you have a direction of spin it's like a
wheel rolling in that direction
and no matter how you orient yourself
to that circle if you don't stop it and
change direction
or bend the plane around your wheel is
always going to be rolling that way
at some point or though you get you get
to a boundary where you can cross over
to the other side of that plane because
planes have two sides
when i do that i'm on the other side of
the plane
and the direction my wrist was rotating
in
in order to make the poi spin towards
the direction it's rolling
changes so right now
my wrist is rotating clockwise no matter
how i orient myself on this side of the
plane
but when i switch over now
my wrist is spinning anti-clockwise
getting to know that
understanding how that feels and
integrating that into
uh what your body does will make a lot
less confusing
your poi is continuing to do what it's
doing
and you're changing as you move around
it
so we played with walking around the
point trying to keep it on a plane
switching over to the other side but
continuing on
you can get twisted up twist
walk backwards
for a challenge you can you can do this
isolated
or if you really want to be brutal on
yourself
try it with a cat eye
what's a cat eye you say then we focused
on
cross points because as you're turning
around and you have to
you have to cross from one side of the
plane to the other
that tends to happen more naturally by
doing a figure ring
we're not often actually walking around
our poi when we're performing
we focused on being able to be accurate
with our cross points and aim them in
different places
a good way to visualize the cross points
of a figure eight once again is with two
hoops
it's not a flat figure eight it's a
figure that's bent around you
so you've got a circle on either side
but they meet
in a point in the middle and that point
can be you can point that cross point
at different angles so we played with
not just
aiming our cross point out in front of
us at the horizon
but moving where we aim the cross point
at different
angles all the way down towards the
ground
hitting a point on the ground bringing
it all the way up
up up to a cross point on the ceiling
with being able to stop turn around
and start spinning in reverse continuing
to hit cross points and bring those
cross points down
so we're playing with getting a full
range of motion all the possible
angles around a big circle that you can
put your cross points at
we also played with this standing morin
wall plane the sort of fencer stance
and that allows for a nice smooth
transition all the way around your body
one thing that will really help with
that if you look at the wall
so in this case i have the mirror wall
and the curtain wall
sort of say that to yourself in your
head curtain mirror curtain
mirror curtain mirror curtain beard
curtain mirror curtain mirror curtain
mirror
keep focusing on that as you make your
turn and you can
make the turn with it over your head
without adding any extra beaks
and if you really want to be thorough
you can also use the
cross point in between your legs too so
you can go all the way around the clock
after you played with cross points with
one poi you can start playing with two
by doing two beat weaves or two beat
mills
and so you can take you can take this
two beat and point its cross point
around a variety of different
orientations
whenever you get to the horizon you
actually have you switch which hands on
top
so you can keep going
so that range of motion really will get
you comfortable with any of the possible
mills and weaves that you can do
it'll get you comfortable with the water
mill going under your leg hip mills
weaves shoulder mills
windmills other shoulder mills so on and
so forth
since we were playing with split time
another thing that's good to practice is
separating your point of two circles
next to each other
at that point you notice that there's a
central focus point
that they keep touching or meeting
while you're spinning in split time
so we actually practice this with just
our hands and then move back to poi
put your fingers together up at shoulder
height that's your central focus point
you move your hands up and down
all the way up to the t up and down
back to the central focus point
really getting used to always coming
is key to being able to hold split time
with your poi separated or your arms
separated
no matter what angle you end up spinning
at
your hands are clapping at that central
focus point
you can make it big
you can make it small you can you can
start out going
same time same direction and then alter
the timing so one's dropping down while
one's coming up
then we we played with turning
from split time same direction as your
point open
out from that central focus point that's
when you can
turn into long arms split time same
direction
and continue turning to use the central
focus
point on the other side
i find that this is a really like easy
way to visualize
these different planes and the cross
points
because here i am here's here's planes
on either side of me
and look at that there's this cross
point i could
cross over with and now i'm just hanging
out on this wall
i could cross over here to this wall i
could cross
back and there's there's my figure eight
or i could
or there's opposite directions right
and what this insinuates is even though
i'm working with a cross point here it
insinuates the possibility one opposite
this cross point all the time
so not only can i cross here but i can
continue
through across and reverse here or i can
follow this diagonal
if i want to do a pirouette yeah and
that that's the thing like really
a pirouette does naturally go at this
slight diagonal
and that's okay like some people i think
when they when they start pirouetting
like continuously their planes get funky
and they either like fall out into
horizontal spinning or they're trying
too hard to keep it like
perfectly vertical and the fact of the
matter is
it naturally a pirouette does naturally
go from
down here to up there that's an angle
from here to there right
and so you just have to sort of be aware
of that and be able to keep that playing
and once you come back to being on one
plane
that's when you flatten out you go from
this diagonal to
a nice vertical plane again if you're
conscious of that and play with it and
feel when you need to shift from this
diagonal pure wet plane back into okay
i'm on the vertical plane again
then that'll smooth out a lot of things
you